oh your apartment is definitely the
loudest thing in the world when you were
filming there someone on the other side
of the wall was going
jeremy stop begging that
pan i don't know are you living next to
monty python
[Music]
a very happy day to you and welcome to
she doesn't read the news with me
chris turner and me alice win hey ellis
win
hi christina it's nice to have you here
thank you thank you for continuing to do
this we live together
i know but you know what if one day you
suddenly were just like
screw you and screw the podcast i have
said that before
yeah luckily i edited out everyone
thinks our marriage is so idyllic it's
all in the edits um i'm i'm feeling
slightly upset because my tea that i
made oh it's
decidedly tepid oh a cold tea so okay
have you ever seen an interview with a
vampire i have not but that's by anne
rice
it is yeah i always saw it was on sale
in bargain bins for like 1.99 for the
dvd it's a weird film
brad pitt grown-up brad pitt kisses
child kirsten duns i beg your pardon
yeah
she's like 10 or something is he playing
benjamin button in this though
then that would make that okay no it was
her first kiss but anyway
i i had a point that comes back to your
cold tea so in um
in interview with a vampire there's this
like plot point
thing world building thing i guess where
if a vampire drinks cold like human
blood
of a dead person that can i think kill
them or make them really really ill
i think that happens to people as well
if we drink the blood of a dead person
we get really ill
really you think you could drink
cold dead blood and be fine i don't see
how that's different from eating meat
it's cold dead blood stop being such a
vegan about it i
i just don't think i just i don't know i
feel like if you're a cannibal you
probably eat colder blood sometimes
no you think you cook it yeah you cook
it cooked blood
that's black pudding that's it i'm
trying to get somewhere with this i
can't wait to see what you're getting we
started with a man kissing a girl
so at one point kristen kristen kirsten
danced
in yeah she um she like
tricks tom cruise into drinking blood of
dead people and suddenly he's like oh my
god what have i done
and i um i always think of that whenever
i take a sip
of cold tea because i
i put the tea in my mouth thinking it's
going to be hot tea
for listeners i'm trepidatiously about
to sip this tea so i can make this
mental connection
and then instead it's it's cold tea like
when tom cruise
drinks what he thinks is going to be
real alive blood but instead it's dead
blood
yeah that's really horrible it's really
one of the worst things i think that can
happen to a person is cold tea
definitely um i mean to a british person
no to any person
well um thank you for making me now
realize that uh
culti is akin to killing a vampire it is
um we we've watched some films this
weekend
we did that's uh the uh the film about a
korean family moving to
arkansas in the 1980s okay so more on
brad pitt produced by brad pitt yeah
it's set in arkansas
whose production company which is called
plan b
has produced three best picture winning
movies the departed
um two other moonlight and one other
film that i can't remember
12 years a slave 12 years a slave and
and they produced manari which is an
oscar contender
okay yeah but this is what i was going
to say it's in the foreign film category
no it's been nominated for best picture
as well i would imagine there's no way
no it's
yeah it has been normally the best
picture i promise you so it's in two
categories
you can be roma was nominated for best
picture and best foreign film
i'll allow it all right now what's your
problem with these foreign films alex no
i just think it's what
do you have against films not in
american do you want to join marjorie
taylor green's new american first caucus
we're getting ahead of ourselves that's
one of the uh
exciting news stories let's just deal
with it now because most of the news
stories i have this week are quite light
because this week has been a bad week
all around the world obviously there's
surges curved surges everywhere
however in america they've really got
back on their horse of
people murdering other people with guns
um
and those people include the police
we've had the shooting of dante
wright in minneapolis which i mean look
minneapolis police if you can't
not shoot a black person when one of
your own is on trial for shooting a
black person
like that's actually the one thing you
shouldn't have done this is the chris
morris joke
like on the brass eye pedophile episode
which i think we've referenced twice now
on this podcast
and we've missed the second pedophile
reference of the show after tom cruise
and kirsten dunst
listen all right go on all my cultural
touchstones
are inappropriately age relationships
um they talk about how they're sending
they're sending um children into space
on rockets because that's the only way
they can be safe from
the sheer number of pedophiles on earth
and then they've launched the rocket
we've just had a report chris straight
in they put a pedophile on the rocket
with the child this is the one thing we
didn't want to happen
um yes so that's a perfect analogy
of what's happened in minneapolis i
guess yeah
so what i'm saying is we can address the
margery telegram now because for the for
this episode i wanted to do
mainly light frothy frivolous stories
because everything has been just quite
depressing
shooting at the fedex facility there's
been
i didn't hear about that one well an
ex-fedex employee went to his ex place
of work and killed eight people
so um am i going crazy i think that
male like post office shootings are a
thing aren't they
well fedex is different but yeah the
going postal the phrase goes postal is
drawn from that yes shootings in america
are up 78 on this period last year wait
really because everyone's allowed out
again right
they've taken their masks off they're
like boom sun's out guns out
to use an inappropriate joke yeah that's
fine it's um you know it's horrendous so
margery telegram we can talk about that
and then we can go back to talking about
your thoughts on minari and uh yes stuff
well i don't have much else to say about
it it was you know it was good
uh margery taylor green has sort of
done the nazist thing i've heard in a
while yeah
i read the press release and it was like
oh you may as well have letter headed
this with a swastika that's how
it was pretty full on um so can you do
you have
written down what what the description
was oh i can i can i can
give you my phone so you can find it um
while i explain
what it is so in in congress uh the
senate in the house
parties have caucuses you caucus
together it's a group of like-minded
politicians so you have the um
uh i'm trying to think the i can't
remember what the precise name is but
like one of the biggest caucuses
is the the black caucus and that's
headed by james clyburn who's the
democratic whip who kind of handed biden
the nomination by
getting the the democratic black caucus
behind him during the democratic
primaries
so these caucuses can have power and you
have kind of republican caucuses and
different kind of you know more moderate
democratic caucuses anyway
margery taylor green everyone's favorite
uh absolute
bonkers person from georgia
she started the american first caucus to
follow in the footsteps of president
trump
and in her statement i know she uses
phrases that are much worse than this
but uh
one of my favorite lines was she said
that it takes a certain kind of
intellectual boldness to follow uh
president trump which uh the first time
i've heard president trump an
intellectual use in a sentence together
alice do you have some of the outtakes
from the caucus i'm uniquely bad at
googling
oh that's okay that's okay i mean it's
good you never find out about my affairs
what
um sorry hello so we have it here
uh margaret hello green uh has
formed a nativist anti-immigration
america first caucus
nativist feels like a euphemism doesn't
it well you have to
have been born in america i think so
arnold schwarzenegger out
ah me out i can't join you but i want to
advance
um anglo-saxon priorities so the caucus
calls for a common respect for uniquely
anglo-saxon political traditions
right when you whip out the anglo-saxon
phrase really good
well i mean if you're talking about the
angles and the saxons and
yeah i mean i guess i'm anglo-saxon
right because i'm from the country that
was
conquered by the angles and the saxons
darling you are an anger
that's not yeah i mean you're not
exactly a celt it describes american
culture as dominated by anglo-saxon and
european influences
america is a nation with a border and a
culture strengthened by a common respect
for uniquely anglo-saxon political
traditions
history has shown that societal trust
and political unity are threatened when
foreign citizens are imported
on mass into a country using a foreign
word there they've imported a foreign
word
into their anti-foreign document also
america came to power after like
many many decades of waves of
immigration
yeah immigration america american
culture
is immigration that's the narrative of
america yeah
so this here it will work towards an
infrastructure that reflects the
architectural engineering and aesthetic
value that befits the progeny of
european architecture
it's it's so sinister and she's scrapped
it now and she's been like i didn't
write that my assistant read it
that was herman i don't know why we
hired him
uh yeah so so she's she's like no no
that was too nazi for me obviously so i
wouldn't have said that
i mean which actually is it maybe maybe
that's a reassuring thing that
that she was like oh actually that's too
far i think she's only pushed back
because trump didn't immediately come
out and say this is a good idea
mcconnell was saying we shouldn't be
saying stuff like this this is a dog
whistle
so she got called out by her empire
mitch mcconnell killed her races yeah
mitch mcconnell
said this is bad bad bad bad why if
mitch mcconnell's calling you racist i
feel like that's
um it's a pretty heavy indictment on
your
politics uh all right well so it's been
cancelled yeah
cancel culture again disgraceful
disgraceful stuff
i was saying to you earlier that i i was
reminded of um and i'm pretty sure it
was dr seuss
who said that when nazism comes to
america it won't be called nazism it'll
be called americanism
[Music]
which i often think of unfortunately he
has been cancelled
and so we can't even include his words
on this podcast i don't think
that just because someone has done
something bad doesn't mean
you can't quote other things they say it
sounds like alice is about to get
cancelled oh no sorry alice don't mess
it's my worst nightmare
yeah um so we we watched minari i've i
very much enjoyed it
it was very good i did not enjoy it i
thought it was very good i can do both
things at once
yeah that makes sense you know i am an
excellent lover however
i don't enjoy having sex with you
exactly yeah exactly uh no it was it was
um
slow it was it was i mean you know it
was very good it was slow
well we watched no madeleine did you
like nomad i thought they felt very
similar it was people searching for
their american dream
i also did not let no man look we're
going to watch promising young woman
which is about a woman who pretends to
be drunk in bars to pick up men who are
trying to
have sex with them so that's why she's
drunk what i want because
all my all i want ever really is titanic
okay and that's the central part of
titanic when
rose is like if i get naked will you
paint me he's like yeah she's like aha
i'm going to get you arrested
rose masterminds the sinking of the
titanic
to get revenge on both her lovers and
then the final twist she throws the
necklace away
great film oh should we just watch it
again no alice and
can we stop bringing it up in these
podcasts literally all the complaints i
get people just saying
she does love titanic a bit too much no
i don't love it too much and i i
honestly think
it's not possible to love it i think
it's like a baby
quickly you have all moved on from the
tragedy of titanic
unless it was over 100 years ago yeah
but barely
barely look that's enough titanic talk
over a thousand people died cancelled
for the second time you being cancelled
um one thing we've been doing at the
moment is we're off to new york to go
and have a look
for some places to live we're going to
move to new york which is very exciting
and i'm very excited to be doing live
shows there and therefore having footage
of the live shows to put up on
sorry i just squeezed alice's toe far
too hard and she responded
with a face of such dreadful pain that i
worry about how strong my hands are
very strong i'm very sorry so we're
moving to new york and chris has been
doing all the work as always
chris does all the work but you do all
the work of being an amazing wife
why are you laughing you're nagging
yourself i'm laughing because i'm not
always going to be pretty and then
we're going to see what what changes i
don't love you for your looks
okay um i don't bring anything
so um what i was saying was chris doing
all the work
he looking he's looking for apartments
online which is sort of fascinating
because you get to see
[Music]
like sometimes there'll be an apartment
that looks really great but it's been on
the market for two years and you're like
oh that's got a ghost
right like that's why that hasn't sold
which really you would think that in la
that would sell immediately because
people love that i mean remember the
time we've been to people's apartments
and they're like
i saw a ghost but i know my crystal
protects me
so it must be a friendly ghost if there
is a ghost in my house if i genuinely
see it goes to my house
not a question i'm breaking the lease
immediately wait here's a question
genuinely and i don't know your answer
on this if you saw a ghost
would you believe it was a ghost or
would you i believe i was i'd been
spiked
what would it take for you to believe it
was a ghost it took
this is very hard to even say i don't
even know visibly
other people like i if i was with some
mormons
people i know would be so but not even
caffeine and they said
no you're right chris that is a ghost
and i'd be like look i think you guys
are mad about your holy book but
i'll trust you on this so i think i
believe it goes pretty quickly
i think if i just okay so say you died
as is my
perpetual terror yeah and you were to
show up as a ghost
i'd be like cool ghosts are real oh no
if ghosts
if ghosts are real i'm coming to hang
out with you
and every time you tr like go out to a
club and like a guy buys you a drink
i'm gonna poltergeist the drink back in
his face do you know what's gonna be
really devastating
to you is is if you die i see a
different ghost
and then you don't come and i'll be like
oh wow he just doesn't want to hang out
with me
wait clarify that so like if i see a
different ghost which proves ghosts do
exist
but then when you're dead no when you're
dead okay and then you still don't come
and haunt me no because what if
ghosts only exist if they have
unfinished business okay all right
because i think that's what we think
isn't it we think that ghosts are
you know i basically don't not believe
in ghosts like i don't believe in ghosts
but
yeah i i would be open to a ghost
hmm any ghost listeners alice would love
to meet you
i will remain skeptical i like asking
this question because i
i think about the fact that if i were a
ghost who needed something to be
accomplished on earth so that i could
you know complete my ghost business i
need to like
know who i could approach so it's good
to know i can't really approach you
but i have a friend my friend chaska who
i think would be the perfect person i
would approach her
i think she'd believe me pretty quickly
and also then try and do stuff
so cheska or haley joel osmond um yes
those are the two options
cool i'm turning sort of progressively
more and more loungy i apologize this is
uh
horrendous um i like this shawl yes it's
a fashion blanket
so it's just you just swaddle yourself
up men often get annoyed at me when i
wear this because
they're like why can't i wear a fashion
blanket and i'm like well
you could you just need to get paid less
so i've been looking around apartments
and virtually
so one if you're listing an apartment
if you have not put a floor plan of that
apartment you will make me incredibly
angry
don't just think that you can show
people photos
of the apartment and you know that the
proverb of like
there's like five blind men describing a
camel
and one's like an elephant whatever it
is and it's like oh it's a it's a long
rope
oh it's a one tree trunk yeah yeah
exactly
how am i meant to figure out how your
apartment fits together if there's no
floor plans outrageous
number two in the age of covid
we understand we might be able to see
your apartment do a video tour
however video tours where they strip the
sound out and put a little noise bed
underneath of like music you go
oh your apartment is definitely the
loudest thing in the world when you were
filming there someone on the other side
of the wall was going
jeremy stop begging that
pen i don't know are you living next to
monty python
yeah mate that's the dream that's the
dream that's capricorn is it okay
so um that also when you are giving your
tour
of the apartment video they need to just
decide
a set time because you'll watch this
video tour and you'll go oh it's a
minute long and it's literally
some disinterested person just walking
around apartment going oh camera facing
in the bathroom there we go camera
can i be a real [ __ ] and tell you how
you've used disinterested incorrectly
yeah go ahead okay so disinterested is
commonly thought to mean like a lack of
interest but what it technically really
means
is just that you don't have a vested
interest so for instance
i am disinterested in the outcome of the
ascot horse races
i don't have a horse in that race oh
very good but i'm not using
double eight people but i'm not
disinterested in what we're gonna have
for dinner just because i'm not gonna
have
because i don't mind because i am
involved in eating the dinner
so i'm patently not as interested so
this is like nonplussed
people say nonplussed means he wasn't
really bothered by it whereas
it actually does not mean that in any
way what does it mean again it means
confused
doesn't it i thought not plus yeah means
kind of like surprised by
i remember cedric diggory is nonplussed
in the fourth harry potter book when
harry potter is named
the fourth harry potter champion so it's
not like cedric cedric diggory is like
oh it was like
yeah what do you mean i'm going to get
killed in a maze
oh poor cedric takes poor little diggers
um don't call him that it's a really
sadie baby um okay sorry to interrupt
your story i just i
don't know sorry i have a sort of
vendetta again this is the thing we have
often we'll do the kind of um onion
knight thing from game of thrones
where he corrects less and fewer right
does he do that yeah he does that in the
thing and i'll do it
with you and you do it with me and it's
good because it now means i know how to
use it however
i will do it with other people you can't
do it
you really just cannot correct other
people's grammar so i'll correct
people's grammar if i know they don't
mind so
or if you're teaching them yeah but i
don't just
generally go because it's a twatty thing
to do really isn't it
and it's a losing battle right i mean
disinterested
is not going to mean what i think it
means i mean what it is what it does
mean so what we mean is uninterested
when we say that yeah
yeah uninterested i couldn't give a [ __ ]
mate well did you know that actually
means you're not
involved in the outcome okay my pet
peeve is people who say
i could care less like i could care less
what you do with your dick
trevor it's like yeah you you could care
sorry
why did that why did that come so
quickly to you i couldn't think of the
name
jeremy a few minutes ago and what who
that who's travis
dick well anyway the point is if you
could care less about something that
means that you actually care quite a bit
because you
could care less so you do care it's just
an extra syllable
couldn't tell us yeah your mum has this
all the time she posts things she'll be
like
based off of god we're being very
pedantic let's move on before we ruin
our reputations as individuals
um so yeah people showing houses
look the fisheye camera thing yeah oh
that's that's cheeky
when you look at a picture and you go
wow that room is massive and then you'll
see it from another angle go wait a
minute
the gap between that wall and that
kitchen counter is about
one and a half feet but because they've
used a fisheye lens an
anamorphic lens that makes it look
widescreen
everything's just like whopped out it's
it's [ __ ] estate agents i'm going to
say it i think you guys are
surreptitious
underhanded manipulative monkeys well
scrupulous
unscrupulous knaves exactly yeah that's
fine they have no scruples yeah they're
just scrupulous
that was a nice giggle i liked that you
should giggle more i'll try
thank you that'd be nice just yeah
yeah men don't giggle very much in
literature no they don't
well you know that i like using feminine
terms yes you like to call little boy
shrill
shrill and bossy oh he's he's a little
bossy what a bossy little shrill
that's a shrills oh you're shrill
because people only call little girls
shrill
little boys are bloody shrill as well
wait can i remember my joke that i came
up with about boss [ __ ]
yes yes this week i came up with such a
good joke
it's very it's a shame that alice
doesn't do stuff just for this
one joke so the joke is i've definitely
built it up too much now
i'm a boss [ __ ] i have a boss
and i'm her [ __ ] it's awkward because
alice is self-employed
um i love that that's great yeah i'm
very uh
i think i'm destined for great comedic
things yeah well hey stick with me kid
you'll go a long way i'm going to mentor
um i think that is probably
it's done for this week do you have any
more news
do we have any more news no does the is
there news oh no there is news no that's
not the end of the podcast
but like i said we're going to focus on
some nicer stories this week because it
has felt
pretty distressing and horrible the
derek chauvin trial has
adjourned the jury are going to be um
deliberating we don't know how long that
will take
what's the longest it could take as long
as until they get a majority of it no
a unanimous verdict that's the thing
they have to get a unanimous verdict
it's a unanimous verdict hard like
you've seen 12 angry men if you haven't
seen twelve engines
so good so good and i know it sounds
like it would just be
[ __ ] and i also think it sounds like
it's gonna be
kind of like philip rothie john updikey
kind of
not very friendly to women kind of oh
okay
film you're just naming authors who i've
read vague short stories often well it's
just like i think there's a certain type
of
like i've never read norman mailer but i
just have bad vibes
and i think it's it you know that's what
i assumed it would be like
in fairness maybe if i were to read
norman mailer i would discover i'd be an
idiot i mean he's very
very male because they had norman and
then
he was even mailer do a giggle no
[Laughter]
i could do like that laugh that vanessa
hudgens does in high school musical
where she's just like
i'm the leading lady i like that i like
that little
little inhale at the end it's cute my
favorite life is jimmy carr
what a great love it's a great laugh um
12 increments it's just great really
really good you should watch it it's
short as well by the way yeah
anyway but the point is we had a friend
who was on a jury i don't know if we're
i'll just say things the trials finished
so it was in england
and it was a pretty clear-cut case of
assault where like
this guy had climbed into this girl's
window
and like attacked her and you could see
his fingerprints on
the outside and the inside of her window
frame and our friend was in the jury
and he was like what was the girl
wearing though because that does depend
was she was she kind of you know
encouraging him yeah no i mean
yeah that's a very good point you know
um and anyway but he was like
because of there's this you know thing
about like can you prove it beyond
a shadow of a doubt kind of that's not
the phrasing i think i remember this
there's some with reasonable doubt yes
and and so
people kept being like oh i don't know i
don't know it could be some doubt
and it could have he could have been
there earlier lifting up the window on
both sides
yeah innocently he was just opening the
window
it was things like he had already been
arrested for assault before
i mean there was so much stuff it was
it's jimmy window
it was like it was just it should have
been such a clear-cut case and yeah our
friend was like
you know it was so difficult to convince
the other people and the jury
that this is what actually had happened
and he was like and there was another
person on the jury who was just like i
don't know
women are [ __ ] sometimes and it's
like what are you supposed to do
i mean the thing is
when you're selecting a jury as a
prosecutor or a defense person
it it's not great for you to have really
smart people
if i was a defense lawyer because if
it's a unanimous thing i would choose
someone who i'm like
they seem indecisive or they seem dumb
they seem like they're just going to be
confused by it because if someone's
confused they're going to be like
i don't know i just don't know and like
you want them on your jury because
that's the person that's gonna get the
person off because they're gonna
you know say oh but can we be sure you
know
yeah so i mean i oh
i mean i think i i dread what's going to
happen if he isn't convicted
or if he's even convicted of
manslaughter
instead of murder having watched stuff
from the trial you just like
every defense witness essentially had to
kind of backtrack on things they said
whenever they were like oh i don't think
a neck a knee on the neck
um kills people and then they're like
well you know
you admit that this happens this happens
this happens and then they go yeah i'm
like okay so
it can they're like i guess it just
seems very strange
yeah it seems a strange thing to be a
defense witness in just be like
clearly anyway we're getting we're
getting too sad
too sad but the point is uh jury duty
is better than other systems but still
not perfect
yeah first news story of this section
um i'm gonna can you guess can you guess
the story based on the song i'm about to
sing i don't know but it feels as if
you're about to propose to me
you marry me you beautiful wife no
sing the song okay move [ __ ] get out
the way
okay so it's a it's a story about
someone telling a woman to get out of
the way
no because that's the song right i
remember once coming up with
um a very funny joke which was what's a
rapper's favorite color
move [ __ ] and then i
found out that uh many many many other
comedians
had done that joke before me it's so sad
when that happens isn't it why twitter's
the worst
because you could just find out oh
that's not original one thing i really
admire about you
is that uh you are not particularly
sensitive about um
whether or not your jokes have been
stolen and like okay
sometimes people have stolen your jokes
a guy in dubai
wholesale stole a set of mine
i think it was uh maybe this happened
twice i think sophie hagan
and matt richardson two very very good
comedians very lovely people
both messaged me saying hey there's
someone in dubai
doing your routine and this is after i'd
stopped doing this routine it was
literally my one-liner routine right
they were doing the pun stick and
everything
and i remember matt i i asked more
because i've known matt for
longest when he told me we had this
conversation and he
he was just like yeah he's ruining your
jokes mate
like they're not really getting laughs
you stole my jokes and you murdered them
and
i messaged this guy just saying hey man
apparently be doing this set
that's not cool i'm sure you've got
loads of great jokes of your own you
know because i don't want to be rude
about it and the guy was like
oh yeah well i'm just such a big fan
that i thought i'd try your
type of humor out to see if you'd work
well at these gigs that i run
and they they really like it so we'd
love to have you there
and as i but that means then that you've
done
my jokes so what jokes am i gonna do now
obviously i had other jokes at the time
but
i was like i don't know why would i do
that i just think that's
sort of sweet actually i mean obviously
not acceptable but anyway the point is i
you know so yeah there have been times
when someone literally stole your stuff
but on the whole you're not like if
someone does a joke that's similar to
yours
you don't tend to be like i can't
believe they stole my jerk you tend to
be more like
a lot of people would think that i think
a lot of people will be like
oh you know i was writing a script about
um the little mermaid
but with somalian pirates and then
someone else also wrote a script about
the little mermaid but with somebody did
you just come up with that idea right
now because we need to trademark it
immediately
um and then they'll be like i can't
believe they stole my little mermaid
somalian pirate idea and it's like you
know someone else could have just
also come up with little mermaid
somalian pirates i don't think anyone
else could come up with that can you do
a song which is
look at this stuff isn't it neat i'm the
captain now
you better get beat okay can you guess a
new story
no okay the french town of
uh beach has had its facebook page taken
down for being against facebook's terms
and regulations
because it contains a rude word and so
facebook immediately apologized
after an outcry from from the all the
you know however many people live there
and my favorite thing was this always
the thing that always happened to these
stories did happen
which is they asked the mayor of the
town for comment and the mayor of town
always says
well i would just like to invite mark
zuckerberg to come to the beach and see
how lovely a town or town is like
he's not coming to your town mate pipe
down
for once just be like a mug zuckerberg
can suck my cook
like just be just say something better
than do you remember in the beginning of
the pandemic when there were all those
viral videos of italian mares just
losing their [ __ ] being like
you're not in i am legend stop
pretending you're
i am like because the streets were empty
and so people were walking around
you know tuscan villages just being like
oh my gosh um yeah
uh i i that thing happens so frequently
people will take um
names down and stuff and then yeah it's
always the same comment
i just feel like he missed an
opportunity to be like well this would
make sense
uh maybe mark zuckerberg is from here
because he is a real son of a bish
like i get another french i have no
humor but come on the french have lots
of humor and i will see
i would like you to stop fighting about
this because the french have great comic
films that you would know about if you
were less ignorant
um i'm not ignorant don't speak their
language that is and if they're like oh
the humor is lost in translation you're
like nah mate come on
you can make it funny darling you
haven't watched any of the french films
i have suggested to uh
music's good music is good it's very
long though isn't it scientists have
invented the world's whitest ever paint
how white is it it reflects 98
of sunlight that that now that is
impressive yeah
and it it reflects uv light and so what
it's going to do
is it reduces whatever it's painted on
below the ambient temperature
so think about this think about how much
energy
air conditioning takes right and think
about how climate change is going to
increase
temperatures in many places we need more
air conditioning
which therefore increases climate change
like a vicious cycle
so if you just paint everything this
white yeah because think about
mediterranean villas right they're
painted white right so just paint them
this color white and this is
cool and they've said in two years they
can have it on the market and it it can
be made like normal paint it's not like
vantablack that pigment that anish
kapoor bought that
absorbs all light but is made from like
micro carbon tubes
this is just from normal pigments that
they just very intense pigments and
yeah it's it's gonna it is a thing that
could possibly you know i wonder if
it'll look nice
what a beautiful shining white well i
don't know
not every building is going to look good
painted white i get that but
it's not that i just mean it's just um
it might look a bit fake somehow
because it's just so bright i mean i
guess one problem is we just be blinded
walking around the streets so
okay um in like murano and barano um
near venice
islands where they make glasses yeah and
they're these sort of adorable little
island um towns with you know
beautiful pastel houses and i i was
there with um a family friend of us
who's venetian
and he was kind of i was looking around
i was like wow this is so beautiful he
just tutted and he was like oh it's not
like how it was
and i was like how is it not like how it
was and he was like well look at these
colors
these are modern colors what color do
they used to be they were pastels but
they were a different type of pastel
they were a different type of paint like
i think
so now that they're painted with like
more i don't know acrylic or whatever
that they're um you have a real vanilla
against acrylic priming
paint acrylic paint i think i was
showing you a little cartoon that had
some painting in it and you were like
ugh acrylics what's wrong with it
they're modern
what's wrong with that all art after
1914 went
down why did you keep bringing titanic
into this 1912
yeah it's the same period i know it
wasn't 1940. my ring is from the year
before the titans from 1911. the last
time men could wear rings because after
the war
men couldn't wear rings because after
that horror why wear a ring that's silly
they didn't know world war one stopped
rings being worn invented wrist watchers
is that a thing really about the witches
now i know that about the watches
but wrist watch it it's cool that wrist
watchers were invented in world war one
because men had these pocket watches and
then they just strapped them to their
wrists
that's not the only cool thing about
world war one i'm sure there are many
cool things but there's not enough time
because i need to tell you all about
world's biggest rabbit stolen from
owner's garden
his name was darius a continental giant
rabbit went missing from his home in
stalton worcestershire
he was a four foot long rabbit let me
show you how big this rabbit was
oh my god it's a big rabbit that's to
try and show our viewers i mean it's
there
it's it's very big that's a very large
rabbit 129 centimeters long
the record holder of the world's longest
rabbit has been for 10 years
um and yeah the woman who owns is very
sad because
she's he's too old to breed oh his mum
was the previous one her name alice
i don't approve of that i'm alice well
that and i think that one might have
been live before you
um offering a 1 000 pound return so if
you did steal this rabbit please give
him back
make a thousand pounds poor rabbit yeah
also don't steal rabbits guys that's not
fair
not fair at all before i give you a
couple more nice stories we'll slot in a
couple of um
not as you know exciting ones i mean i
guess it's exciting the us
is pulling out of afghanistan i don't
know
the context or enough of that to know
whether i should be good happy about
that
well i mean yeah again it's complicated
because you know the first gulf war and
then the second gulf war came out of the
first gulf war because they left but um
america invaded afghanistan after
september 11th
and they've been in afghanistan ever
since which makes it america's longest
ever war
yeah uh it doesn't seem
like something the afghanistan people
will be sad about
well so the the taliban who are you know
the previous rulers of afghanistan under
the taliban in afghanistan they uh
they had a rule that if you were a man
you had to have a beard your beard had
to be
as long as a fist underneath your chin i
would have been flogged
every day i've been having a real hard
time although if i was in afghanistan i
think i would probably have
the genes that allow me to do that right
yeah
these inferior anglo-saxon genes
margaery taylor green our genes
suck there are a couple of other i mean
there's a lot of things i don't know i'm
just getting this from that um
book a thousand splendid sons which is
great by the way uh
but is that how many sons afghanistan
has
yeah that's 500 the number of tatooines
it's uh it's a lot more sons than
anywhere else
no wonder people get so angry there hot
there yeah
um so trump wanted america to pull up
afghanistan by
may right so i think that the fact that
trump wanted it is what makes me feel
well i think the thing with trump is
that he did he was like why are we
wasting
money and american lives in wars his
reason wasn't
why are we getting involved in these
countries and killing them his reason
was
why are we letting american people die
you know so it's not necessarily like
that hey we shouldn't
be killing people in another country
right um
but you know it's still a commendable
thing to want to end a war right that's
a good thing yeah it's just whether it
is going to leave the region stable
enough
um probably it won't right probably
we'll look back after the third gulf war
and go oh we should never have pulled
out but
things have never gotten in the first
place but regardless the taliban are
celebrating as a victory because they're
like oh well america
left and we're still here in charge i
think afghanistan's very hard to invade
i don't think it ever really has
been successfully invaded yeah i mean i
guess it all goes back to cold war stuff
right because the russians were getting
involved i mean britain
had stuff in afghanistan in you know
how little i know about afghanistan
considering how much
various countries i am from have meddled
with their
history well america's pulling out
so you know we'll developing story we'll
keep an eye on it we won't though
because it's
just definitely going to be boring and
sad something boring but it will be sad
yeah it's not really boring i apologize
afghanistan
it's not boring 1000 spend it sons very
good read thousand splendid sons
another another kind of you know news
bernie madoff you know him
no he's the the guy who run the ponzi
scheme
i think i read it my phone just took a
suicide dive to the floor looking
just like bernie madoff i lost so much
money with him
so bernie madoff is the one where i read
i think a romance novel
about no you didn't it wasn't about him
but it was about
it was about a fiction the fictional
bernie madoff style person's
son which is so the thing is in real
life bernie madoff's two sons who worked
for the company didn't realize what he
was doing allegedly and they contend
they didn't one died of cancer and one
killed himself two years after his
father was
really sad yeah yeah bernie madoff has
died in prison
serving 150-year sentence so he was
always going to die in prison he was
already in his like you know 60s when he
got jailed
um yeah i mean he stole 60 billion
dollars of money that's so much money i
wonder who's the person who stole the
most money
that seems like that must be an empire
um
yeah now that's a lot so it was a ponzi
scheme you know ponzi schemes okay
explain them to me because have you read
martin chuzzlewit or little dorit
no i haven't and you haven't either no
but they they have their dickens novels
which have ponzi schemes in them before
ponzi schemes were called ponzi schemes
really because ponzi was a man from the
1920s who did it so well
that they named them after him um so
ponzi scheme is
early investors get guaranteed returns
of money
and they think they're investing in
something all they're getting money from
is people who are investing after them
right and so then if you're a late
investor there's no one to invest
and at the start you get your money um
and so that's good but it for them to
work it relies on them always continuing
it has to be exponential
growth which you know you can't do put
you know one grain of rice in a
chessboard double every time
soon all the rice in china's gone yes
thank you for explaining that to me
you're welcome so he's dead
good riddance well criminal
um didn't steal any of my money i'm just
saying there was a bbc article which
said
said bernie madoff has died in prison
how should we mourn him not at all
i don't you know my feelings on this i i
uh i think
there's a little bit of decorum that i
i'd like to hold ari when people die
r.i.p bernie
no i mean look i just i don't think you
have to be you know you don't have to be
we love you bernie that's not what i
would say
sounds like alice is a big bernie madoff
fan
also who's trevor i keep wanting to sip
from my tea
darling you can't sit from your teeth
because like the blood of dead people it
will kill you
um two nice stories to finish this off
uh number one
you know colin the caterpillar yeah wait
call him the caterpillar
the legendary porn star no i'm sorry
what
cause his dick is so big it's like a no
a car in the caterpillar
is a cake yeah the cake yeah how old
that cake is first introduced i don't
know
1990 it is almost my age
um that cake is one of the most
delicious cakes in the world yeah so for
those of you who don't know
alice describe it because you're the one
okay who i think has a must for it
caterpillar is so good that i think we
even had one at our wedding
we did we had multiple caterpillar cakes
much nicer than the wedding cake so
colin caterpillar is a cake
it's is it mark's expenses yeah okay
cost seven pounds which is about you
know nine dollars
and it's just like a chocolate cake it's
in the shape of a caterpillar and it's
encased in chocolate and it has a big
caterpillar phase
so the caterpillar it's it's a like a
swiss roll type cake right which is
sponge rolled up into a cylinder with a
kind of chocolaty filling inside in this
instance
covered with melted chocolate then set
so you have a hard chocolate cylinder on
the cake
decorated with some like smarties or
like little kind of gums and then the
front
is a white chocolate you're actually
making me so nostalgic we're going to
have to stop
you can't okay it's too delicious so
this cake has been
a best seller i think they've sold 15
million
15 million colin the caterpillar i pray
that you tell me the news is not their
stopping
the caterpillar no the news is that
colin the caterpillar is having his day
in court
i beg your pardon because aldi
introduced cuthbert the caterpillar
for five pounds say undercut colin
and let me tell you if you look at the
photo side by side
martin spencers are saying that aldi are
misleading them because you might have a
cuthbert and think it's a colin
you definitely wouldn't it's uh does it
look like does it look like um
those like you know how they'll be like
cinderella and it's a great film
and then there's like cinderella three
and a half straight to vhs yeah
and it's like oh they all look like they
were the same animators they got yeah
they got these animators who were
actually like
tattoo artists but they're doing some
animation in their spare time
and it's just like a nightmare is that
what it's like it looks pretty bad but
apparently the quality is pretty shonky
now
aldi is a supermarket it's actually
pretty great right aldi owns trader
joe's one of our favorite supermarkets
can i just say though that
cuthbert the caterpillar is really not
trying very hard
like couldn't they have just been like
allegra the the millipede
well you'd lose out on the you know
millicent the millipede would be good
oh yes alliteration was important i see
that now inez the inchworm
exactly um yeah yeah no the really they
should thing is
i feel they could have got around if it
wasn't a caterpillar there were loads of
things so yeah
into a millipede if they just had sam
the slug although that's the thing like
how many kids are like oh my
actually kids would love sam the slug
i'll do you [ __ ] make sam the
slug you bells
so so colin and cuthbert in court now
yeah
it's gonna be like that jaffa cake court
case do you remember well that was just
because mcvities wanted to dodge tax
yeah and they just litigated to prove
that jaffa cakes were
not a biscuit and it is true because
they go stale
they go hard instead of to avoid vat
value-added tax which adds 20
to the price of things in the uk and
yeah
it's whether something is a necessity or
a luxury
and a luxury has v8 added and necessity
doesn't and for some reason cakes are a
necessity
biscuits are a luxury or it's the other
way around whichever it was they were
arguing they're the one that doesn't get
taxed no it was kate because because
they argued that jaffa cakes are a cake
okay because biscuits when they go stale
i think we're interested in this but no
one else okay we'll move on but anyway
[ __ ] colin i hope you trounced that
imposter
i don't know i'm actually i'm [ __ ] off
cuthbert i go back to germany i think
there's space for cuthbert and colin
both you know
no look i think you should be able to
have a slightly cheaper version of colin
the caterpillar i just don't think you
should be able to pretend it's colin the
cat
am i being a dick seven pounds is quite
cheap for a birthday cake that feeds
like
eight kids i mean that's still quite
expensive is it i feel seven pounds for
a cake is expensive yeah
for a cake that feeds like a lot of
people i mean with kids you probably get
a dozen slices out of it that's what i
mean yeah yeah yeah i mean that's okay
how much that breaks down to per slice
of cake yeah it's like yeah yeah
i'll do some math later i mean i'm not
saying it's not you know a treat but it
is
it they're not over they're not like no
they're not gouging you it's not
like you know like we need to take down
colin the caterpillar because if they
beat
if they beat cuthbert the caterpillar
and then they'd jack it up to 25 quid
colin that'll be a bit disgraceful
in the caterpillar well we'll we'll have
to get you one um and when we next do it
we'll film you eating it and everyone
can then see what's going on
um final thing in this is a news story
from poland
i think this is probably my favorite
news story
of the last few weeks i shared this with
your mother and she was delighted
a frightened resident called polish
animal control
because there'd been a bird of prey sat
outside her window
for two days and she was so terrified of
this bird that she
says i i couldn't open the window i
won't open the window but couldn't
because what if it flew in and got me
and so animal control show up and
they're like
what the [ __ ] is that and they point
this like humongous brown
thing just hanging out in the tree right
outside this apartment
and they get closer and they realize
it's a croissant
and someone had thrown a croissant out
of their window to feed the birds it got
stuck in a branch of a tree
and it just sat there upright so it
looked massive and flaky and brown
apparently just staring straight into
this it's
the baked good the croissant right i'm
saying crossover craftsman
croissant croissant yeah well that's why
i said croissant
right in america they say croissant like
because it's because kanye goes hurry up
with my damn croissant
um yeah here they say it weird but i
guess no british people often say
and and people often have a habit i
think of uh
it's very scoundrel i like using french
words as they are
is it in that margie taylor green thing
i should have pronounced that i should
have gone you know
um so in uh croissants apparently
came from the the turkish
turkish army or something well i'm now
getting coffee
coffee and croissants right hang on
isn't it a vienna thing
isn't it when the turkish were invading
australia and they fled and they left
coffee in croissants was it turkey was
it turkey or was it moores
i don't think we know the story well
okay i think there was some ottoman army
yeah and they left and they'd already
i'm sure it was austria no but i think i
think it was to do with the baker boy
saving the day and then
the croissant is in that shape of the
crescent yeah
i think these are two different stories
we're combining it's possible coffee was
when the army left and they left the
coffee there everyone was like oh this
is really good
yeah and the croissant was to celebrate
something to do
with the turks because of the flag
anyway
um there was a croissant in a tree
someone thought it was a bird of prey
see now you know it's a croissant you're
gonna think oh yeah that's clearly a
croissant
but it's it's not clearly a croissant it
does kind of look like a very
threatening thing
it looks like some weird alien owl is
just hanging out in the tree just like
this like [ __ ] fat
move it's just like waiting for you to
open the window so it can come again
just flake all over your apartment alice
when that's the end of the news so
jonathan you want to teach us about this
week yes
yes you said yes if you're about to
follow with queen i thought i would tell
you a little bit about richard wright's
autobiography
um or memoir i think it's i don't what's
the difference in the memoir in an
autobiography
i'm not particularly sure memoir feels
like more literary maybe
yeah and maybe an autobot memoir is less
about your life it's thoughts that you
had during your life
yeah i don't know which this is really
so richard wright um
famous american author he's most famous
he wrote native sun
which i haven't read but i've read black
boy last summer and i'm reading it again
at the moment and
um the first chapter is just
so like bombastic like so many things
happen
instantly in this first chapter and it's
only like 35 pages long
but it opens with um so
richard lives in the south it's um
i think he was born in 1908 and he's
four years old so that's
four years before titanic yeah the same
year that
titanic and so he clearly writes about
all that because that's most important
no but he does briefly mention the war
the great war the great war of 1914
which i appreciated
anyway uh not in this chapter so um he
he's four years old he's living in the
south um he's black
this book is called black boy and um
he's waiting in the living room with his
brother
his younger brother who's three and he's
been told
to be very very quiet because his
grandmother is ill and he's so bored
and there's nothing to do and so he
starts staring into the fire
and then he's like i wish i could burn
something so he thinks
what about the broom so he starts
pulling out twigs from the broom and
burning them in
one by one and they're fascinating but
after a while and his brother was like
stop doing that you're gonna burn up the
whole broom and he's like shut up
um so after a while he's like what if i
were to bring these broomstick
pieces to the beautiful white curtains
because there's these beautiful like
special occasion white curtains that are
up and they're just gorgeous and never
allowed to touch them anything so i
wonder what it would look like if the
fire touched them
so he catches i know is he an idiot he's
four
four-year-olds understand fire so he
takes our cat understands fire no he
doesn't
that is true but
for a while so he sets fire to an end of
broomstick
you know straw and brings it carefully
over to the curtain and his brother's
like what are you doing i'm gonna tell
and richard's like shut up
and he sets fire to the curtain and it
catches um just a little bit of red
embers at the bottom and he's like oh
that's so interesting that's so pretty
and then suddenly flames just burst out
right
and he's like oh no and
um he's freaking out because the
curtains just are being swallowed up by
fire
but all he can think about is the fact
that his mother is going to like beat
the [ __ ] out of him
and he's like oh no how can i stop my
mother from finding me
so he turns around his brother's gone
the whole front of the house is now on
fire
he leaves the house and climbs
underneath it
to hide from his mother's punishment
which he's much more concerned about
this is a very american thing isn't it
houses
that are lifted up off the ground right
so is that for heat reasons
uh well i don't know i think in the
south it's often
oh because of schwa
it's combining marshland swamp swamp
uh so he hides under the house and um
soon he can hear everyone
running out of the house and the fire
trucks coming and the whole house is on
fire and his mother looks
like looking for him everywhere being
like richard where's my son where's my
son and he won't come out
and finally his father comes out looks
underneath the house
sees him and is like come out and
richard's like no
and the father's like come out and we're
just like i won't and so then the father
pulls him out by his arms
and richard's just like don't beat me i
didn't mean to don't beat me
um and his mother beats him
so hard that he almost dies
like the doctor comes to visit
afterwards and is like he can't move
from his bed for like weeks otherwise he
will die
he's four years old and he just burnt
down their house
when i was about seven i was on a
caravan site
and pete there this couple were fretting
and were so worried
because they had left the burner on in
their caravan and they had closed the
door and it locked
and they were worried they were karen
was going to burn down and
everyone there was like we don't know
what to do we don't want to do and then
i
climbed through the tiniest gap in the
window in the caravan
turn the burner off and they were like
thank you so much you're such a hero
what a hero you are and then they beat
me until i almost
died so so he's beaten to you know
within an inch of his life
and um why is it always imperial
measurements why can't we be beaten to
within a centimeter of our life
come on get with the time so he's beaten
and uh he has all these like feverish
hallucinations and blah blah and then he
kind of recovers
and then not long after this there's a
lot more to happen in this chapter just
so you know
it's a lot so not long after this
uh they move to the city uh
i've got in the city they moved to a
city and um
his father kind of stops coming home and
takes up with another woman
and so
leave trevor alone uh and so there's no
food and so he and his little brother
are just like ravenously hungry and
there's this scene where he goes up to
his mother and he must be like five
years old and he's like
can i have some food and she's like no
and he's like why not and she's like
because there is no food and he's like
but what do you mean because i'm so
hungry and she's like
well have you seen your father because
if your father doesn't come home there's
no food
and it's just like horrible and so
finally she gets a job
working um like a white family uh for
that you know in that kitchen
which means she leaves five-year-old
richard wright alone in his house
presumably she's not got curtains in
this one with
his and to look after his four-year-old
brother
and she'll just like she'll leave them a
pot of tea and a loaf of bread in the
morning and then that's all imagine how
cold that tea would be
um and so that's all they do all day and
so
um one day when he's about six um he
he likes to sit outside the bar and
watch the drunkards
and one day one of the drunkards says
hey you want to come inside
and he goes okay so he comes inside and
someone goes hey let's buy more whiskey
and they're like yeah that'd be funny so
they buy him a whiskey
and he doesn't want to drink it but they
make him drink does he say whether these
people are black people or white people
i think it's implied that they're black
people um and
they like play them with alcohol and
then they'll they're like the men will
like
whisper things to him and be like hey
i'll give you a nickel if you go and
tell that woman over there these words
so he'll go and like
toddle drunkenly over at six years old
to some woman and be like
and like whisper these scandalous words
and then the woman will be like oh
and then the men will be like hahaha and
so this is his life and he becomes
addicted to alcohol like
he can't go without it all he can think
about is his next drink
at six years old and um
his mother like is completely at a loss
and keeps speaking to the bar owner in
the bar owner finder and finally is like
okay he can't come inside the bar
but the men are so excited about how
funny it is to get six-year-old drunk
that they keep
like sneaking him drinks outside of the
bar it's definitely
very funny to get a six-year-old drunk
i'm not saying you should do it but like
that's well funny six-year-olds already
seem like they're drunk
so so he um he only stops being an
alcoholic when his mother finally hires
an old woman to look after him every day
um and then she starts giving him drinks
but then i can't remember exactly what
happens next
i think he ends up in an orphanage for
some reason
um and he tries to run away um
i don't know it's just it's i it's just
all really rubbish and i just want to
emphasize that this all happens in the
first
chapter yeah and if you wrote this in a
screenplay people would say calm down
mate spread it out a bit
there's more stuff as well it's things
like um he
no never mind i'm gonna not do it
justice all i'm saying is very good book
everyone should read it second time
you've read it as well so it must be
good yeah yeah it's i think it's better
the second time around
why because the first time you read it
you're like one unlikable horrible [ __ ]
protagonist
who's getting drunk and starting
fighting he's so interesting because
he's
he's like so like curious and reckless
and desperate to learn but no one will
teach him anything
um and so he keeps you know when he
learns like swear words
he's so excited about having learnt new
words that he takes a piece of soap and
goes and writes the swear words on all
the windows of his neighborhood
and then his mother gets called and is
like why has someone written [ __ ] on all
of our windows
and she's like come here richard you
know wash your mouth out with soap i
used it all to write the swear words
well she made him wash all the windows
down every single one
well thank you very much tell us about
richard wright yeah so that's black boy
by richard wright
lovely stuff well go check it out um
obviously you can always find reviews of
alice's books that she reads on her
instagram
let them eat books with underscores
instead of spaces thank you chris that's
all right um should we do a wrap oh
yes go on what you want to do one yes
you're right oh my gosh
that is the end of the uh news and the
story so we're going to wrap
about the week's news stories alice is
going to say them to me
i'm going to wrap them over this little
beat give me the first one in about six
seconds my little love
let's get that beat cranked up alice is
going to throw the new stories at me
this is the rap stealing rabbits
stealing rabbits
let's do it let's do it
[Music]
a problem bad behavior you better stamp
that out got a rabbit but not rampant
and it's in my house ever so large like
four foot two
can't breathe anymore so what's the
point dude why you trying to prove you
be
a master thief a cat burglar now you
really should cease
calling yourself that you gotta have it
not a cat burglar
that's a rabbit you're gonna go and grab
it you get your fingers get your touch
pull it out the hutch let me say that
the scientists are clutch cause they're
saving us
98 of the sunlight reflected no uv
in the fight against the climate change
got a painting light in the
mediterranean get the pigment it's
insane for them to get
all the reflection you know so what's
the effect called
that's the albedo that's how the
sunlight is reflected
if you are in the war oh i know you
heard this before been about a century
since they developed
get a little finger leather and make
sure it is enveloped around your wrist
you can read the time you're like ah yes
oh no
and now i die machine guns at the song
but i know it's 12 o'clock
oh it got shot too so that stopped the
wrist watch
and i'll risk switching out the beat
moving on alice when come on
getting all of this now you tell me
getting kind of wealthy
being like aldi telling everybody hello
guys we are german i know that colin
caterpillar
is preferred to many other kegs but ours
is better it won't hurt
your wallet as much it's 2 poundless for
cuthbert i know that
m s marks and spencer's taking cuthbert
to course yeah they're no longer friends
a little colin is acknowledging ascended
to jail and now these little kind of
trademark infringement at my scale
margaery taylor green oh he's obscene
have you seen
all the words from marjorie taylor green
well apparently she hadn't
she said it wasn't aid she pretended to
cry and be so dismayed she's like
oh i'm really sorry oh i've got a thirst
not for racism or nativism this was not
rehearsed properly
i didn't even see i apologize for being
kind of nazi
anglo-saxon architecture that's the type
that i respect when it comes to donald
trump whose footsteps will we follow
next try and be intellectually bold when
i'm here on the hill
ah hey tiny child wanna take this pill
no
that's very bad but i'll be quite risky
i'll say [ __ ] to that lady if you give
me a whiskey my name's richard wright i
know it's not right for me
to say this ooh fire makes me excited
maybe go on holiday the french town of
[ __ ] pronounce it beach and facebook
they heard and said
oh hey i'm mark zuckerberg and the merry
beast
says mark calm down you need to come and
visit us come on down to our town
buy a ticket to beach you can chill on
the beach but there's not a beach there
because it doesn't border the sea
it's the end of the beach they kind of
fade out oh it's a faded yeah
yeah what are you gonna say cold tea ah
[Laughter]
not good tastes like a vampire with dead
blood if you want to have a sip then it
tastes [ __ ]
cold tea don't zip it there we go yeah
hey look alice when wins
i'm sorry what did you rhyme blood with
should i don't know i don't know that's
the most like
andrew marvel like half rhyme right like
deserts of
eternity look i think i think you know
virginity
what's his rhyme that he does yonder but
all before us lie doesn't it
turn a tie then worms will try that long
preserved virginity right look
california to rhyme with whatever you
know snoop dogg
i think you're rhyming somehow sometimes
it's you know it's
it it's it's like andrew marvel that's
only because it's marvel
i thought that was very good i thought
it was good too it's very good um
do you need my um validation and
approval what
me of course i do um that was a lovely
rap you're a lovely wife that's the end
of the show
anything else you want to say that's me
done that's you follow on instagram
follow me on instagram
and uh i'm gonna be in new york uh from
the 26th so there might might be some
shows if you listen this april 26
2021 onwards for maybe a kind of period
of 10 days i'll be there doing shows so
check out the comedy seller website it
would be lovely to see there
tell me you listen to the podcast if you
do this in the podcast in general even
if you can't come to show thank you very
much for listening
please do spread the word leave a little
review on the apple podcast app
subscribe to and all that type of stuff
it puts a smile on my face and it puts a
smirk in a giggle on my wife's face
that's it
doesn't it not yeah you don't smoke and
giggle every time i say hey alice i
don't spend very much time giggling i'm
afraid
yeah goodbye you